herr maßen ich will die frage gleich
weiter geben herr laschet hat gerade
gesagt sie würden sich an die linie
halten müssen die er als bundeskanzler
vorgibt werden sie das tun also zunächst
einmal guten tag und ich würde armin
laschet wählen und ich empfehle auch
allen wählern die sich an mich wenden im
wahlkreis 996 in südthüringen armin
laschet cdu zu wählen und
selbstverständlich die cdu ist nicht
eine monolithische bach teil sollen
einfach teil mit verschiedenen flügel in
verschiedenen positionen ich vertrete
eine position auf jetzt ziehen alle an
einem strang und in die gleiche richtung
und ich denke wenn wir uns in der partei
auf einem kurs verständigt haben werden
auch alle diesen kurs dann auch
durchsetzen und umsetzen ich glaube
nicht dass man sagen kann dass alle auf
einer linie liegen kathrin cdu
bildungsministerin in schleswig holstein
und mitglied dem zukunftsteam von armin
laschet hat im fernsehen gesagt sie
würde lieber ihren spd gegenkandidat
wählen als sie sie haben daraufhin ihren
rauswurf gefordert der es allerdings
nicht erfolgt im gegenteil herr laschet
hat gesagt er hält sehr viel von frau
prien
das ist eine frage
habe ich dann den nagel
ich fand es war unklug gewesen dass ihn
sich so geäußert hatte sie müssen sehen
wir stehen derzeit in einer sehr sehr
schweren wahlkampf situation muss immer
wieder den wählern erklären warum sie
cdu wählen sollen warum sie mit der
zweitstimme armin laschet wählen sollen
in einer derartigen situation sich so zu
äußern auch wenn wir vielleicht
inhaltliche konflikte miteinander haben
ist aus meiner sicht unklug und hilft
uns in der situation nicht armin laschet
hat entschieden dass bei ihm im team
drin bleibt das habe ich das akzeptieren
aber
herr maßen sie haben jetzt gesagt frau
prien habe sich unklug geäußert nun hat
sich erleichtert aber fest hinter sie
gestellt und wollte auch selbst nicht
sagen ob er sie wenn er denn in
thüringen leben würde ihnen ihre stimme
geben würde was halten sie davon dass
der cdu-chef und cdu unions
kanzlerkandidat nicht sagen will ob er
sie ein cdu bundestagskandidaten wählen
würde nun als rechtsanwalt würde ich
gern laschet auch immer empfehlen sich
nicht zum spekulativen fragen zu äußern
er ist nicht im wahlkampf 196
wahlberechtigt er darf mich nicht wählen
und daher braucht er sich nicht dazu zu
äußern dass viele leute immer zieht wo
hinter mir stehen sollte ihnen auch
bekannt sein jens spahn hatte sich an
dem abend auch zu der frage geäußert
klar gesagt dass er dankbar ist für alle
die in den wahlkreisen wahlberechtigte
die cdu zu wählen und damit auch nicht
befehlen
arnold vater der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende weil jungs bei mir
gewesen hat mir unterstützung zugesagt
der landesgruppen schrift manfred grund
steht hinter mir also ist nicht so dass
meine position hier isoliert wäre ganz
im gegenteil ich glaube ich vertrete
eine sehr starke gruppe in einer
flasche zeigt sie aber auch in trier
weil sie in der mitte der cdu steht da
nicht das stimmt doch oder
nein das stimmt nicht aber ich glaube es
ist eine ansicht
laschet hat seine position von mitte ich
habe eine andere position von mitte wir
sind eine große gemeinsame volksbad ich
glaube jeder der partner ist ein mittel
begriff worten herr maßen eine bekannter
neonazi hat dazu aufgerufen ihnen die
erststimme zu geben die afg mit der
zweitstimme zu wählen ruprecht polenz
bekannter cdu politiker schreibt ich
erwarte von den maßen dass er sich diese
wahlempfehlung öffentlich verbittet und
klar sagt dass die afg eine völkische
nationalistische und rechtsradikale
partei ist die die cdu politisch
bekämpft würden sich hier von ihrer
wahlempfehlung distanzieren das ist eine
aufgedrängte wahlempfehlung die ich
nicht erbeten habe ich nicht möchte
ich habe den eindruck es wird eine
wahlempfehlung ausgesprochen
vielleicht um mich zu diskreditieren
von daher diese wahlempfehlung nämlich
bekenntnis und wird von mir in keiner
weise
erbittet genannten das heißt ich
verstehe das so sie sagen sie
distanzieren sich ausdrücklich davon ich
distanziere mich von dieser alle
empfehlung von neonazis ich habe sie
nicht erbeten
herr maßen sprechen wir einmal über die
koalitionsfrage armin laschet hat beim
tv duell am sonntagabend nicht
ausgeschlossen dass er in eine groko
unter der führung von olaf scholz
eintritt was ist ihre haltung sollte
sich die cdu diese option offen halten
und als juniorpartner in eine gruppe
unter der spd-führung eintreten nun das
ziel muss sein dass die cdu und csu
stärkste fraktion im deutschen bundestag
werden und die regierung stellen das ist
das große ziel und nach möglichkeit auch
mit der fdp das ist jetzt in
meinungsumfragen wahrscheinlich nicht
bewacht
wenn es zu einer koalition
kommen sollte wo die cdu mit der fdp
nicht zusammenkommen kann dann
möglicherweise auch mit der spd politik
dafür sorgen sollte dass das programm
der union weitestgehend durchgesetzt
wird alles andere ist jetzt zeit für
mich spekulativ und darum möchte ich
mich darauf nicht einlassen auf jeden
mit der spd als juniorpartner koalieren
wirkt alles klar dann lassen sie uns
nicht über spekulationen sprechen
sondern über den streit den es immer
wieder über ihre person gibt in der cdu
mit karin prien beispielsweise als
seinen letzten großen streit denn es gab
vielleicht kommen ja noch weitere vor
der wahl glauben sie dass sie mit ihrer
kandidatur der cdu einen gefallen getan
haben und weiterhin tun also stärken sie
die cdu oder schwächen sie die partei
ich glaube nicht ich weiß es und das
wird mir jeden tag hier im wahlkreis
gesagt dankbar dass ich antrete dass ich
der stimmen wegnehme er sich positionen
vertrete in nur wenigen jahren
mainstream innerhalb der union bin und
ich bin überzeugt dass ich meine mission
hier die afd zu schwächen aber auch
viele protestwähler die zu hause bleiben
würden oder die fdp wählen zurück
erklären sie uns doch einmal bitte wie
läuft es gerade in ihrem wahlkreis ist
es ein kopf-an-kopf-rennen zwischen
ihnen und dem afd kandidaten was wissen
sie über die aktuelle gemengelage bei
ihnen im wahlkreis
ich weiß es nicht und ich glaube es war
kaum einer bundestagswahl insgesamt aber
auch in den wahlkreisen die in meinem
wahlkreis so unübersichtlich wie jetzt
gespürt fühle ich mich jedenfalls dass
ich rückenwind habe viele viele menschen
auf der straße beim ausbau wahlkampf
auch im abgas unterstützen mich zeigen
daumen hoch und sagen gut dass ich
kandidiere
aber letztendlich ist das nicht
repräsentativ wir wissen es erst am 26
ab 18 uhr
ich nehme der afg die stimmen weg sagen
sie mit welchen themen sender wollen sie
die wähler überzeugen die eigentliche
fdp wählen wollen lassen sie uns auch
noch mal zurückkommen auf den satz von
armin laschet er steht nicht in der
mitte der cdu wo stehen sie genau wo
sehen sie sich selbst ich sehe mich
einfach als realisten er möchte dass wir
einen rechtsstaat sind in denen das
recht auch durchgesetzt wird ob das das
ausweisung und abschiebung recht ist wo
wir weit über 300.000 ausreisepflichtige
ausländer haben und ich sage ich möchte
dass das recht durchgesetzt wird oder
dass sicherheitsrecht wo ich auch sagen
ich möchte das mit einer einheitlichen
maßstab gemessen würden das
drogenpolitik nicht so ist dass man
alles duldet wie in berlin am görlitzer
park dass man auch in der drogenpolitik
hat bekannte zeit die bekämpfung von
kriminalität durch migranten ist ein
ganz wichtiges thema gerade hier zurück
wo ich sage hier muss der staat hat
bekannte zeigen klare abgrenzung
gegenüber denjenigen von rot und grün
das weiter dulden wollen wo ist da der
unterschied zur afd
der unterschied zur hälfte besteht darin
dass die afg war in teilen positionen
oder probleme ausspricht die menschen
haben aber diese probleme nicht mit sagt
mal rechtsstaatlichen positionen oder
mit nicht radikalen lösungsansätzen
verfolgt ich bin jemand der ist der
meinung wir müssen die probleme die die
menschen hier haben die die sie sehen
aussprechen wir dürften sie nicht unter
den teppich kehren aber wir müssten sie
lösen auf der grundlage der freiheitlich
demokratischen grundordnung
und des werteverständnisses der cdu
vermaßen sie sie grenzen sich immer sehr
klar von der fdp ab aber sie haben
kürzlich den öffentlich rechtlichen
rundfunk propaganda vorgeworfen
hierbei bild wir kritisieren öffentlich
rechtlichen rundfunk natürlich auch sehr
häufig immer dann wenn fehler passieren
aber
warum sprechen sie von propaganda die
unterführung unterstellen sie den
gesamten öffentlich-rechtlichen rundfunk
dieses wort ist das nicht doch
vielleicht afg sprache
das entscheidende ist nicht wie man
etwas ausspricht sondern was man aus
spricht und dass wir in deutschland ein
problem mit dem öffentlich rechtlichen
rundfunk haben der nicht mehr ausgewogen
berichtet und auch nicht mehr tatsache
in aller tatsachen breite darstellt ist
mittlerweile allgemeingut
das sagen allensbach das sagen andere
meinungsforschungsinstitute dass ein
großer teil der bevölkerung dieser
ansicht ist jedenfalls bei mir in
thüringen wenn ich von jedem zweiten
bürger darauf angesprochen und das muss
auch öffentlich thematisiert werden das
muss auch vom öffentlich rechtlichen
rundfunk thematisiert werden als ein
eigenes problem dass der öffentlich
rechtliche rundfunk hat und lösen muss
lässt der öffentlich rechtliche rundfunk
nicht öffentlich rechtliche rundfunk tut
so als ob alles wunderbar wäre und dass
man einfach so weitermachen kann das ist
das zentrale problem und es nicht das
problem wie man es ausspricht soll das
zentrale problem ist dass der öffentlich
rechtliche rundfunk es nicht ausspricht
und damit auch nicht das problem
überhaupt lösen will sie werfen den
öffentlich-rechtlichen rundfunk vor dass
er dinge nicht ausspricht
sprechen wir in diesem zusammenhang
wieder einmal über armin laschet als es
um den 11 september ging um das gedenken
an die islamistischen attentate hat
armin laschet genauso wie viele andere
politiker das wort islamismus nicht
erwähnt über terroristen über eine
tragödie gesprochen aber das wort
islamismus kam der rechten kam nicht vor
in seiner rede er wollte es nicht
benennen finden sie das richtig
ich weiß nicht was seine motivation war
dass es den ausdrücklich ausgesprochen
hat ich bin der meinung probleme muss
man benennen benahmen und islamismus ist
ein problem dass wir in deutschland in
den westlichen gesellschaften haben
das waren georg maßen
umstrittenes parteimitglied der cdu der
in thüringen antritt danke für das
gespräch bitteschön
[Musik]